whole system is broken
media system is broken everything
there's a lot that's broken there's a
lot that's broken right now one thing
that's broken is the place that i came
from i came to a place that's not as
broken florida's doing great i left new
york city broken
shattered wrecked
wrecked talk about falling apart at the
seams go take a trip to new york city if
you haven't been there and say you
haven't been there in 10 years take a
walk around and see the deterioration
the crime it's despicable what's going
on over there that's my city that's my
home i love it despicable why you ask
well i came across this story
this was a good one
new york post
remember the defund the police movement
remember all those people that were like
the police they get too much money we
need to take that money out of the
police and we need to put it towards
social programs
remember when they were advocating for
social workers to do the jobs of the
police do you remember that i do tyler
does he's shaking his head he knows
okay new york post hypocritical defund
the police defund nypd advocate moved
out of harlem why you ask for safety
issues
this is a great story and illustrates
exactly what's wrong with these people
let's take a look
a left-wing state lawmaker who has
pushed for cutting police funding first
moved to the district she is seeking to
represent in congress because safety
issues near the projects in harlem
prompted her to shack up with her tech
bro then fiance in the financial
district the post has learned
her name is yulini oh i may be saying
that wrong i apologize like i always say
my name's jedediah people get it wrong
tell me how to say it better and i'll
say it better next time
regardless assemblywoman
she told a publication in 2016 when she
was campaigning to initially get elected
to her current seat that she headed to
the wealthier manhattan neighborhood
because she witnessed a pair of
disturbing crimes and fell victim to one
okay
she says i actually was rob when i was
living in harlem my boyfriend at the
time my fiance didn't think i was safe
up there so he told me to move in and
that's how i moved to the financial
district
so she had the option to leave right
anyone who doesn't know new york city
let's go through this for a second
financial district is downtown manhattan
it's where your your twin towers were
it's now where the uh freedom tower is
it's a it's a bustling area with
just a lot of people who have a lot of
money down there beautiful apartment
buildings it's safe generally now i
don't know i don't spend a lot of time
there a lot of places that used to be
safe aren't safe in new york city
anymore but at the time it was
considered safe she had the option
she was dating a guy the the post report
also talks a little bit about him
uh david segura apparently founded giant
media it says in an october 2012 report
segura predicted the company would make
eight million dollars in its third year
so apparently he's doing well great more
power to them i have an immense amount
of disrespect for people who are
successful great what i have a problem
with is that she left
the area where all the crime was
she knew that was a reality not
everybody had the opportunity to pick up
and go move in with somebody in a ritzy
area not everybody had the option that
she did at the time those people were
stuck there what about those single moms
that were stuck in that crime-ridden
area afraid to walk their kids across
the street to the store past a certain
time of night and maybe even during a
certain time of day
she left that she knows what was going
on there and she decided to then move
into the ritzy area and from that perch
in the ritzy area advocate for a defund
the police movement
that's hypocrisy i can't have that
i cannot have that and that makes up so
much of the defund the police movement
this reminds me of the people the
celebrities who walk around
they say you can't have guns ar-15s are
dangerous
we it really it's a stain on the country
and then you see a photo of them they
hop out of a car and three guys around
them
seven foot tall
with
guns to protect them
you can't have it you can't have the
police protection we need to defund the
police there's too much money you can't
have that extra police protection
you can't have that gun to protect
yourself but i can i can move to the
financial district
i'll be okay
disgusting
this stuff is disgusting
disgusting think about all those people
who suffer at the consequence of
defunding the police of having less
policemen and police women on the
streets having those departments have
less funding and can't escape
to a rich fiancee's apartment
in the financial district
i'm guessing that they wouldn't be
voting for her you know whose backs are
cynthia nixon
cynthia nixon from sex in the city who
probably can afford to have as much arm
security as she wants while she's out
there talking about how guns are bad and
you
being able to protect yourself and your
family is a bad thing
i can't with this stuff anymore
and what's always fascinating to me is
about the deep fun the police movement
they simultaneously want these people
simultaneously want to defund the police
and disarm you
do they want you to die i ask this
sincerely
you can't you don't have a gun in your
home because they don't want you to to
defend yourself okay you pick up the
phone to call the police and because the
the police movement has been defunded
money has been pulled and stripped they
have less police officers so that that
person you call is busy doing something
else they can't rush to you they get to
you a little bit later maybe there's a
10-minute delay on that from what would
have been
who suffers you do
you do maybe you don't have the luxury
of an armed guard outside your door the
way the cynthia nixons of the world can
afford to do this stuff is serious
these people are hypocrites this
hypocrisy is dangerous and it's costing
people their lives
can't imagine why people left new york
city like they were being chased by a
monster can't imagine
so there's lots of policies that are
sinking cities the defund the police
movement is one of them what that has
done not only that defund the police how
do you think that made all those cops
feel
those cops that were laying their lives
on the line and i'm not saying listen
i'm not saying every single cop out
there is a great person and i'm not
saying we can't have a conversation
about police reform and immunity and all
that stuff i'm here for it let's have it
let's have it
but there are a lot of good police
officers out there that get up every day
and they go out and they feel like
they're doing a good job they feel like
you know what i'm out here i'm going to
protect people i'm going to do what i
can
they've got to hear oh defund the police
defund the police
what does that do to morale in the
police department
what do you think bill de blasio did for
new york as opposed to rudy giuliani
when everybody felt supported
it makes a difference the same way that
the u.s navy doesn't feel supported
right now because they have to sit and
watch a child's video about gender
pronouns
instead of getting ready for potential
combat
okay
so lots of policy sinking cities
not just new york city all around the
country it's a big problem if you like
the short clip you can catch another one
here or you can catch the full episode
right here
[Music]